it is time for this week's pet project
and amy lee
joins us from the nspca and she brought
along someone who needs a safe
and good home you have sam with you
today i have sam who is the sweetest old
man he is 10 years old he's a sharp
payment obviously he's
a little too comfortable right now but
november is adopted senior pet month and
that's the reason why i have this sweet
senior here
sam at 10 years old is a wonderful
companion he's so sprightly he loves his
treats
and our senior for seniors program
actually launches next thursday so
seniors
over the age of 65 can come in during
our senior hour from 9 to 10
and adopt a senior pet that's over 10
years old at no charge
um so we've got lots of great cats and
dogs that are over time that would just
be calm and loving and would
love to find a home with a great senior
oh that's wonderful and sam
is uh looks to be pretty mellow and
is that does that hold true for the most
part you nailed it sam is super mellow
he's sweet he gets along with other
animals
would love just nice and easy walks he's
a little bit arthritic so he just takes
a supplement but really other than that
he's got lots of years of love you know
left in him and he he would just make a
great great companion for somebody great
family member
and what is the life expectancy for a
dog like sam
you know we can't ever truly predict you
know he is a mix i mean
with proper care you know we'd love to
see dog make it to 15. i mean truly
um and i think sam there's trees on the
ground so sam's obviously more
interested in that but yeah really with
proper care with vet care with the right
food right diet
um right exercise you know it you'd be
surprised so i think sam
sam is really great he's so sprightly
too you can't you can't say no to this
face he's so cute
he is a cute dog and as always you
invite people to come down there and
spend time with sam or any dog
or animal they're interested in adopting
yes absolutely so you would make an
appointment online our shelter just
because we're observing you know proper
social distancing you make an
appointment online it's super easy
you come in you spend time do a meet and
greet if you have current pets at home
we invite you to bring your dog over to
meet sam in person just to make sure
everything
you know works out great with with the
two animals but you know he gets along
with everybody so i really don't you
know
he's such a good boy amy it's always
great to see you thank you so much
thank you all right if you're interested
in adopting a pet you can go to
nevadaspca.org
or call them at 702-873-7720
rocky